no hay tregua por la pascua ortodoxa en
ucrania sin embargo los niños en quien
intentan preservar sus tradiciones en
medio de los ataques y los bombardeos
decoran los huevos tradicionales con
cera de abeja y pintura un símbolo
icónico de las pascuas en ucrania y que
este año adquieren un tono más
patriótico la vid se actúa
y muchas personas han optado por desviar
un poco la tradición no dibujando las
imágenes habituales como las estrellas y
las flores en su lugar dibujan lo actual
como el símbolo del tridente de ucrania
o escribirle más como gloria a ucrania
gloria a los héroes
rodeados de los recuerdos de la guerra
los ucranianos de todo el país se
preparan como puede para las
celebraciones de pascua
esta fiesta es muy importante porque
significa cosas nuevas la resurrección
en el contexto actual es aún más
importante
no pasa lo mismo en rusia donde la
celebración de las pascuas avanzó como
es tradicional los creyentes ortodoxos
asistieron a una vigilia nocturna en la
principal catedral de moscú
las velas campanas y procesión fueron
parte de la ceremonia que estuvo
encabezada por el presidente putin y el
alcalde de la ciudad el jefe de la
iglesia ortodoxa rusa el patriarca kiril
ofició la misa en la catedral sin
críticas de la guerra viejo sadar ayer
brasil estaría de ser la piedra blair es
nuestro pasión cada uno de ustedes con
una vela puede recibir este fuego del
santo 100 por hoy me pasma en 80 extrema
llamados a una traigo a la paz como
hicieron el secretario general de la onu
y el papá francisco no fueron escuchados
y las esperanzas de un alto al fuego
durante el fin de semana de la paz
cuarto doxa se desvanecen en medio de
los bombardeos y combates que continúan
sin respiro